قررت ارسال فريق
انقاذ مكون من حوالي 370 شخصا للمساعده في
عمليات الانقاذ ايضا وزير خارجيه السويد
اعلن استعداد بلاده لتقديم المساعده الى
تركيا وسوريا في
للمساعده في جهود مكافحه او في جهود
مكافحه او عفوا جهود انقاذ التي
تبذلها او يبذلها الطواقم الطبيه في كلا
البلدين بالعوده الى الزلزال طبعا
الزلزال وقع في بازارجيك وهي منطقه قريبه
من مركز ولايه كهرمان مرعش الزلزال بحسب
هيئه الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه افاد بلغت
شدته 7.4 وبعمق سبعه كيلو مترات في بازار
كان هناك هزات ارتداديه اعنفها في غازي
عنتاب بواقع 6.6 ايضا الهزات الابتدائيه
وصل عددها الى 66
حتى الان مازال هناك تحذيرات من افاد الى
المواطنين في هذه المناطق من وجود هذا من
هزات اخرى